at this point in time military strike
against Syria certainly looks likely and
all sides are rattling sabers in way
that we haven't seen before
but a couple of big questions remain was
this actually a chemical attack and is
there a way to avoid airstrikes a
military strike against Syria is on a
hot boil at the White House but the
press secretary Sarah Sanders saying
today
it may not be inevitable that's
certainly one option but that doesn't
mean it's the only option in a tweet
this morning President Trump suggested a
missile strike was imminent taunting
Russia which is threatened to shoot down
American missiles over Syria the
president tweeting Russia vows to shoot
down any and all missiles fired at Syria
get ready Russia because they will be
coming nice and new and smart you
shouldn't be partners with a gas killing
animal who kills his people and enjoys
it the tweet brought howls of hypocrisy
from some corners isn't this the same
president who trashed President Obama
for telegraphing his military intentions
he certainly hasn't laid out the
timetable which is would be broadcasting
his intentions other critics took aim at
the president for not having a cohesive
strategy on Syria announcing one week
that he wants American troops out now
threatening a military strike I think
the president does not have a serious
strategy and I think one off attacks or
tweets
or missile strikes are not the same as a
strategy the president's national
security team including defense
secretary James mattis huddled with the
vice president at the White House today
to go over options Matt is saying
earlier today that the u.s. is still
awaiting confirmation that chemical
weapons were in fact used in Douma we're
still assessing the the intelligence of
ourselves and our allies we're still
working on this we stand ready to
provide military options if they're
appropriate as the president determined
Russia continues to deny that chemical
weapons were used as senior military
official today saying the attack was
staged by rebel emergency responders the
white helmets it is a lab son
investigating the territory visiting the
medical institutions featured in the
footage by the white helmets questioning
of medical personnel and patients we
found no evidence of poisoning
substances or victims among residents of
this town in a series of tweets
President Trump today said our
relationship with Russia is worse now
than it has ever been and that includes
the cold war and he blamed the
deterioration on the molar investigation
tweeting much of the bad blood with
Russia is caused by the fake and corrupt
Russia investigation the president is
still peeked about the raid on his
personal attorney Michael Cohen part of
what the FBI was looking for was
documents related to the infamous access
hollywood tape it appears to be an
attempt to link the tape to the stormy
Daniels payment was Cohen trying to
avoid more bad publicity to protect the
campaign did the payment constitute an
illegal political contribution president
Trump incensed that the Malheur
investigation may have strayed well
outside the bounds of its initial
mandate the president certainly has been
clear that he has a very deep concern
about the direction that the special
counsel and other investigations have
taken his President Trump again
considering firing Miller he has gone
from flat denials to a far more
ambiguous posture certainly the
president's allies are warning against
it look I think it would be a mistake a
grave mistake by the press
the fire had Robin bowler I have no
belief that he will the Cohen raid may
be an attempt to put pressure on Cohen
to cooperate with prosecutors threatened
him with campaign finance related
charges in the hopes that he will roll
over on the president certainly Cohen
has a treasure trove of knowledge about
President Trump flipping the president's
personal attorney would mark a dramatic
escalation in the momentum of this
investigation